i remember
when i was on wall street and i first
started to sense
what the federal reserve was and the
role
it was playing but in your evolution
as an investor in your evolution as
a student of the markets and somebody's
studying the structure
when did the when did the federal
reserve first come onto your radar
screen because it was a lot later
in life than october the 20th 1987 when
alan greenspan put out an advisory that
the federal reserve stood ready to back
the banking and financial systems and
within days and weeks was
leaking information to wall street bond
trading desks ahead of fed moves to
inject liquidity in the system i mean
is it 1987 that the fed put was born but
i didn't know squad about the fed until
me personally that the run up to the 90s
uh that the dot-com
days yeah so so people tend to forget
that when alan greenspan came on as you
pointed out
he started in august and by october we
had a crisis on our hands right so
paul volcker was viewed as you know the
greatest fed chair in history he had
saved america from inflation
now i obviously you know you you may
have heard me dispute that and i have
some real questions about
those dynamics but alan greenspan
did step in in 1987 and did something
really important it wasn't so much that
he
offered to bail out the banking system
as what he really did was he facilitated
the provision of
lines of credit and made good the lines
of credit for the market makers right
the specialist firms
so i mentioned spear leads in kellogg
which was the largest specialist firm on
the new york stock exchange at the time
i actually traded commodities for them
but the the challenge that you had as a
market maker
is that you used large amounts of
leverage against a relatively small
capital base to facilitate orderly
transactions in a then manual order book
where
orders would come in and you would
actually try to match a buyer and seller
and if there was an inability to match
that buyer and seller you would put your
capital up against it
and so in the crash of 87 the specialist
firms had extended
their capital and used borrowed money to
buy
stocks to try to facilitate a liquid
market as the market fell out from under
them
the losses that they faced on those
books made their bankers their banking
relationships nervous
they then pulled the credit lines for
the specialist firms which destroyed the
liquidity effectively there was no bid
at that point
and alan greenspan is in the air flying
from dallas so you've got the head of
the new york stock exchange
i'm good friends with arthur cashion so
i wasn't in the pits at the time but
arthur cashin's walked me through that
day but continued
yeah i know so so art cassian actually
is the gentleman responsible for
getting a hold of alan greenspan and
saying look this thing is going to go
straight to zero
unless you guarantee these specialist
firms and get these lines of credit back
open
that was where greenspan stepped in and
said okay listen we'll make you
we'll make the banking system whole on
any losses associated with specialist
firms not being able to make good on
these bets
right and that's really what they were
at that point is just that they were
bets
that was kind of the first introduction
of the fed put
it played a significant role in halting
the panic associated with 87
but interestingly enough i would
actually say that that that wasn't
really where the activist
it may have been where it was born but
that was kind of
untouched for a period of time like the
fed didn't really play
that active of a role in markets at
least on my analysis
until we came to kind of the ltcm type
dynamics
and at that point at least the
the tequila crisis of mexico yep
orange county went poof in the same year
so
but yes long-term capital management
well with long-term capital management
something changed on a structural basis
right so the fed
suddenly began focusing its interest
rate
activity its interest rate movements on
not fighting inflation which is what it
had done since basically the 1970s
instead it shifted to trying to manage
the expectations channel by preventing
collapse
of asset prices right so one of the
challenges of the 1970s and the
breakdown
and so now you have to go all the way
back you know to that time period if you
think about the 1970s
we kind of had this very simple
mechanistic view which is you know this
sort of keynesian
or post-keynesian view that what we
could manage demand by the government
increasing taxes
increasing spending we could keep
unemployment low we could keep the
economy going etc
and in the 1970s many of those
relationships broke down
or at least indicated failure right so
the phillips curve for example which is
supposed to govern the relationship
between unemployment and inflation we
simultaneously had high unemployment and
high inflation which is not supposed to
happen
right the demand component and so the
fed
very much had to shift to fighting
inflation or at least what they thought
they were doing was fighting inflation
and that changed in 1998 and it became
very clear
in terms of the relationship of interest
rates and asset prices
that what had been a phenomenon of
taking the punch bowl away
to use the the warren miller reference
the arthur miller i'm sorry
um reference warren miller's a ski uh
documentary maker
um the uh
you know you took away the the old
reference was you would take away the
punch bowl by raising interest rates and
reducing speculation
post 1998 it became when a negative
financial event occurred i.e financial
conditions tightened
the fed would respond by cutting
interest rates to try to facilitate
borrowing to try to facilitate lending
activity etc
and that was a very substantive
structural change that occurred in 1998
it's very clear in the data
and in my view that's kind of the origin
of much of what we refer to or bemoan as
the activist fed
okay well i'll have to send you a very
boring paper i did about 1998 and
long-term capital management when i was
inside the fed yeah so if you can get
through compliance at the federal
reserve it's not going to be too
it won't keep you up so okay um
so 1998
uh at that time
where was vanguard where was passive
investing
where was there even an etf back then i
don't think so
um but but take us back to
1998 1995 that era
so if you go back to that point and and
you know if you're thinking about the
growth of passive investing or where
vanguard was right so
circa 1994 1995 vanguard and
all other index providers are less than
two percent market share
right so very small relative
to the overall investment universe
vanguard was obviously the leader even
at that point
but two important things happened in
that time period the first was in 1994
the levitt administration of the sec
did a giant study on derivatives because
the challenge that you had had prior to
that point
was that mutual funds were restricted
from using leverage
in most situations by the investment
company act of 1940
they were also prohibited from buying
securities they could have a first
claim on assets effectively leverage
which included derivatives and
in derivatives are also included futures
so the levitt administration did a giant
study in 1994
evaluating the risk of allowing mutual
funds to
use derivatives as in particular futures
is really what they were focused on less
on puts and calls
as we think of derivatives and the
reason that this
appears to have had a lot of impetus is
tied to the challenges that vanguard
and others even at that small size were
having
in maintaining their index providers
focus
right so they began to experience what's
called tracking error where you know you
would issue an s p
500 fund you're supposed to very closely
track the index
but if you're not using futures to track
that index
you're forced to go out and try and buy
every individual security
some of those securities are much less
liquid than others
and by participating in that manner
you're influencing the price of those
securities
in your portfolio relative to the index
that then means that you have tracking
error and that's the kiss of death for
an index
provider strategy so that whole sec
investigation of derivatives in 1994
appears to have been done to facilitate
index providers beginning to use futures
and address this issue of tracking error
and when that happened it led to an
explosion of the utility of futures
right so as a equity market participant
in the late 1990s
while most people were very focused on
the dot-com dynamics
the single most interesting thing that
was actually happening was the explosion
of volume that was going through futures
and beginning to go into index funds
which grew rapidly from kind of two
percent
to about 10 percent over the next couple
of years
so um so that would be
if you will that watershed moment
was that was that the big bang for
passive investing
or was there more market history to come
it was was passive investing was there a
moment
later in time that it became the end all
be
all because it i and
actually at the time i mean one of my
biggest clients at the time was trading
massive spider
futures just massive hedging his
portfolio i mean the world was blowing
up i mean because
i was on wall street during the late
1990s and you've got this other guy
slinging it around with with spys every
day
in and out but was there a different
catalyst was there a big bang moment for
passive investing
so that was one of the key catalysts
right so
so that period 95 96 the beginning of
what greenspan referred to as a rational
exuberance in my analysis
this is largely tied to the growth of
passive investing in the use of those
futures and and just very quickly the
reason why that happened was because the
indices were improperly constructed at
the time they were built on what's
called a market cap weighted basis
which means that you're trying to buy
shares in proportion to the total shares
outstanding
the unique feature of the 1990s was that
you had a number of large market cap
low float companies that had what we
used to refer to as high levels of
insider ownership and so these would be
companies
like walmart and microsoft and cisco and
dell
right when the index providers were
trying to buy these in proportion to
their market cap
relative rather than the float adjusted
weightings that were available the
actual shares that you could have
purchased
it meant in companies like microsoft or
dell that you were trying to buy twice
as many shares as were actually
available
if you try to buy twice as much of
something you're going to cause it to
outperform
that led to the dot-com cycle now
i sat outside this as a as a you know
value manager and
and basically watched some components of
this
similar to what we're seeing today that
construction of indices led to dramatic
underperformance of value investing
because you were not
you know basically benefiting from this
they tended to be older companies that
had all of their shares outstanding etc
right and they also did not fall into
the technology space
so there became some very serious
disconnects that occur
that was kind of the first part of the
growth of index investing was the
the facilitation of that the second
thing that happened was in 2004-2005
they changed the structure of the
indices and then a very
important but you know somewhat
innocuous change was made in the 401k
space which was the introduction of what
we're called qualified default
investment alternatives
and this is part of the pension
protection uh i think it's called the
pension protection act
of 2005. the idea was very simple
that up to that point if you went to
work for a company and you received a
401k and you saved money into a 401k
there were two things that people were
worried about one was relatively low
levels of participation in 401ks
that was a function of you as an
employee had to make a decision when you
joined a company that you were going to
participate
in the 401k so it was an active choice
um in 2005 they changed that they turned
it into a passive or the default choice
so that when you work went to work for a
company you were automatically enrolled
in a 401k
unless you refused to to do so
so that single change was huge in terms
of participation
the second thing that happened was when
you used to go
to work for a company get a 401k you had
to actively choose what products you
would invest in
if you didn't make a choice it would
just go into a money market fund
and so your money effectively would not
be invested
in 2005 that changed with the
introduction as i said of qdia's
qualified default investment
alternatives
which meant that your corporate hr
manager was selecting a fund that became
the default
and almost inevitably that became some
form of balanced
or passive vehicle and that was then
further changed in 2012
with additional regulatory changes under
the bureau of labor
the department of labor that switched it
almost exclusively to target date funds
and so target date funds have been
by far the fastest growing space in the
industry
they've gone from non-existent in 2003
they literally did not exist prior to
2003.
by 2012 they became the default and
today
nearly 80 percent of all dollars going
into 401ks are flowing into target date
funds
80 80
um the the really crazy statistic is in
excess of 60
of 401ks now only have a single vehicle
in them which is the target date fund
okay since i left the federal reserve
i've been doing my own investing so i'm
i'm really happy i don't know about
these
innovations shall we say